[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
making of des clips de l'été on pas
enfin d'après mon corps tu gagnes pour
toi nos clips demain et après demain
mais avant ça s'est fixé le projet de se
transformer en dse dos tarde-t-il de
l'été attention maintenant une flopée de
stars qui ont fait des de l'etec sa
fille à l'écran voilà en gros doit
ressembler à ça je ne suis pas laver les
cheveux depuis six jours parce qu'il
fallait que j'aie un maximum de sébum
pour protéger mon crâne mais vous savez
ce que j'ai fait quand j'avais 16 ans du
fait une allergie à une teinture cette
photo de la profondeur que la tournée
partout ça m'est arrivé dans la vraie
vie marge heureusement ici présentés
extrêmement mauvais temps qu'on a fait
un test d'allergie mais au final tu le
prends du calage palinges et j'insiste
là dessus mais j'ai eu un vrai
traumatisme si vous faites une [ __ ]
teinture fait un test avant vraiment
c'est hyper important faites le au
lavage assez froid s'est désagrégé pas
précisé pour qu'on aille au portugal
parce qu'il nous faut un temps de rêve
et quoi de mieux que le portugal pour
faire ça à sa droite aux as tu fait
moins le malin nanotubes la garde robe
qui a porté ses lunettes qui a un visage
aussi large
c'est la tête à qui ça et freddy une
note sur 10 pour la tenue de la fri dur
c'est un 8 sur 10 sinon quelque chose
parce que la peinture et y en aura dix
et on est arrivé il a réalisé les plus
grandes vidéos youtube la jda stéroïdes
à ses 500 plier le roi du rap battle la
cartouche est aujourd'hui va réaliser
deux clips supplémentaires pour la
chaîne m6 dire que dira t il
salut les lignes tram où l'on m'a dit
j'ai l'impression d'être à la gym besoin
d'être un mac book air chaud qu'une est
très joli salon de coiffure juste
champion après six jours semblait laver
à la la la la quel plaisir c'est comment
je vois son regard
regardez son visage d'admiration ça me
fait plaisir aléatoire ça mais la
température - la température est mieux
que la position quoi c'est moins clair
il a mis du temps à avoir un avis on
voit le résultat va voir si c'est ma
couleur
et attention tout le monde et du ça
passe très bien à tous
c'est agréable non voilées anthony
valider ses hommes je vous dit
j'aimerais m'habiller comme ça tous les
jours
la visage pression à quoi je doute
et voici ma 3e tenu que je me régale à
30 ans mais moi je pense que c'est mieux
quand c'est reparti je prends sociaux
nous avons fini avec des coiffures les
teintures les coupes de cheveux
ça me fait très plaisir nous allons
finir avec les tenues est ce que vous
êtes content de vos tenues tout vitré
s'annonce très content même dans le
making of the press après je regarde
mais trop lentement
les gardois tout poète défaut star de
hip de l'été maintenant il va falloir
faire défaut clip de i de l'état attend
là juste là on est d'accord mais
d'accord pour van cleef celle à 100% par
une attache et qu'on a pas le même
regard ma gueule c'est pas assez classe
et on n'a pas eu une idée originale une
rien d'original tout couper vous avez
envoyé à brice à théo way un truc bien
clichés d'un gars qui conduit une bonne
ferrari belles voitures et avec des
meufs
ouais voilà très simple nous avec jordan
comme on s'est basé sur un truc un peu
latino on veut faire une grosse soirée
avec des pleins de figurants qu'il danse
et à côté de ça la suite des choses
ayotte
le planning les ja c'est que là on part
dans deux heures pour l'aéroport ensuite
on arrive au portugal demain on tourne
le clip et après nantes on vote clip et
j'ai hâte de tourner voilà je peux vous
avez fait un petit canard mais en tout
cas super g
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes pedro de la bourgade
fils de lyon allez il est temps de se
transformer en but chasse garcia c est
bien le seul maintenant faire manger une
banane et à nous diriger vers notre
premier le tournage le bateau bon on est
devant le bateau on va avoir beaucoup
les fûts ce poisson bien matin mon tabac
on se fait présenter le bateau qui
présente la burqa la sur confiance que
tu veux rire
peta a longé la
ah oui un chercheur dans ce tour et
tueur et marraines
souviens quand tu mates rappeler un soir
choisi j'en avais un concept pourrait
faire un guide de l'été en trois ou
quatre tournées dans un mayol pourtant
des bons la célérité de ce flop celle de
ne pas tomber et de faire le mec trop
stylé sûr de lui dise kif
alors prenez juste fébrile et qu'on veut
pas tout prix à la mer tu étais libre ou
ses voeux pour la gym c'est une première
fois du poisson perroquet
[Musique]
awan chaudron qui n'était pas à dix axes
trassard en calvaire les bacs sont trop
l'équipe
c'est drôle pour les clips on dirait que
c'est trop vous avoir un bateau qu'on
s'est régalé qu'on s'amusait tout
embryon d envoyer à faire plaisir
là vraiment les gens se rendent pas
compte la taille a rien qui marche c'est
l'horizon que tout ce que tu veux mais
je suis passé je veux pas talons j'ai
regardé le ciel
c'est ce que j'ai fait ça va pas je n'en
mangez trop domise avais je vais me
faire vomir sa g
elle doit tisser la trame qui l'avait
qu'il ya du vent est envoyée
les mecs c'était un des plus beaux
moments de ma vie trash peu bon mais sur
les conflits retour encore
yapo loi la gerbe
[Musique]
d'accoster et wanna go celle ordonnée
les parties en disant je mette à londres
je sais pas où vous et tous vos rappeurs
préférés
baudis dans leur clip space le bateau
qui sortent pas making of pour le
montrer à l'ouest où tu es assis par
terre mais je suis là mais je ne vois
pas quel est votre avis un 3e ont surgi
très content attention on va se reposer
un peu on va aller à la villa on va
tourner tout ce soir la fosse fait avec
38 ans
[Musique]
banane cv9 fillon c'est très beau temps
il doit faire 24 25
greg beugnot est ce qu'on est prêt à
tourner oui alors c'est parti et à ça on
est seul couple et jordan il a surtout
discuté avec des gens et d'un coup là la
fille arrive il la voit et il se lève et
il veut tenter sa chance et tu sais on a
retiré les gens qui dansent bordeaux
l'évolution des fins du premier masters
donc la soirée à l'intérieur c'est
énorme c'est trop bien ces méga crédible
j'ai pas transition tu martin c'est à
toi en live au bar qui discutent tu as
eu deux visages comme çà de là tu vas
sur le fronton à ray ban et il danse du
spectacle qu'il était ma danse et on
passait à la télé c'est lui qui a trouvé
un peu mal d'aidés du clip c'est pour ça
que le produire comme les lasers sur mes
projets je laime de et il est loin il
travaille les lois seront appliquées dès
l'annoncé que ce qu'il est loin des
bruits ne le dérangeait pas
je
[Musique]
mais comment ces bourdes ou et bien
bonjour j'ai un making of nous devons
finir la scène nous finirons or je suis
fatigué le temps de finir mon master à
moi c'est très cool et surtout les
danseurs ils sont trop gentils et bien
rêvé d' ancien café de complète qui est
trop bon il vous est plus connu en deux
secondes
il a plu à tout le monde et je les ai
apprises aussi pour la faire ça donne
vraiment un délire son de l'été le fait
qu'une chorégraphie tout ça vraiment
drôle jardins d'antan l'apprendra pour
le troisième et dernier tableau
confettis et la poule parti je me rends
compte qu'en fait dans le cas pour les
gros looser parle d'une meuf non une
musique entière on n'avait pas fait un
pas vers l on appelle ces justes
d'insondables sur une vie qui est déjà
mac est heureuse épanouie elle a
peut-être même un non franc et dont
della sera tout en fin de tournage on
est on a fini à l'eau il est très bon
merci jean talon à chelsea on a posé on
avait l'équipe je suis content et quand
c'est le rendez vous se dit 1 2 et 3 et
bye bye bye bye baby baby gère tellement
je découvre on découvre les rushs ça
c'est le plaisir de l'ordre d'un
tournage on regarde un peu parce qu'un
film est de rassembler on est heureux
quoi la manquer ce décor de rêve mais
pas le reste ici en vacances trois
miradors c'était vraiment
donc c'est un avion qui vous appartient
c'est quelque chose de personnel c'est
très personnel et ça me touche beaucoup
créé beaucoup pleuré pour
l'enregistrement en fait un café un
petit peu de fruits
l'équipe est en grande forme c'est faux
barjane le premier spot en gros c'est le
début d'une route bloquée par les fruits
qu'ils ont bloqué une route pour qu'on
puisse filmer tranquille qui est pas le
stress tu sais d'autres conducteurs soir
où tous à condition qu'elle pensait voir
aux films et aux doigts on en parle mais
au stade et c'est vraiment cool ça juste
que pour la ferrari j'ai fait une
recherche
j'ai tapé vitesse maximale j'ai vu 317
kg mais c'est la vitesse à laquelle on
va là sauf qu'à cinq minutes on m'a dit
mec 20 25
ouais vraiment les cadeaux le buzz de
leur syndicat les joies et qu'il roule
pas plus de vingt-cinq soir avec le
drone est tombé dessus
nous allons sur les lieux l affaire à
riquet juste à gauche et la police a
fait des jeux c'est incroyable le truc
qui m'effraie c'est qu'à chaque fois il
me fait attention à la fête c'est un
truc que je suis pas libre de denture
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant c'est assez vieillot
ouais ouais mais ferrari maxim gougeon
assez ouais c'est un record je suis
désolé désolé sur un canal vidéo les
couilles de faire arriver premier plan à
un groupe à suivre la voiture roulait
pas vite prenez tout de même un max de
plaisir
régalez vous faites vraiment les mecs
laisse énorme char ou 3g c'est parti
avec son portable mais finalement il
nous voit très mal faire arriver jusque
là
j'adore me plante d'une ferrari cela
[Musique]
quant à christian spectre
m
venturi la veille
[Musique]
insolation au programme merci au
portugal
prenons nous avancer parti c'est la
deuxième fois que ça m'arrive dans un
cul propre à faust avec maxence dans le
placement de produits voilà pour
l'anecdote
de tournage officiel bourg de cars et
lulu et moi en plus je vais pas rester
avec vous jusqu'au bout parce que je
prends l'avion ce soir le prendre demain
à midi avec jules tâche demain à faire
si vous avez des potes avant ce jour ils
vous disent précisément ça ça devient
instantanément des amis nv l'égard des
grands de lebron et on ce soit à paris
les gars dans merci cameron merci mon
binôme envoie un message merci pré rond
merci la glâne ans et je faisais ma
connexion je te dit bye bye bye bye
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
le maire depuis clairement mis mes
chaussures avec les chaussettes dans
l'eau du sable de l'eau dans mes filles
et valises vol on va tourner des plombs
je crois dans la ville et à la fin ça
finit notamment sur un plan crépuscule
pour du 25 avril à lisbonne le
connaissez elle voudrait faire la totale
a vachement manger entre temps
[Musique]
vous arrivez à lisbonne j'ai essayé de
faire chaud se sécher mes chaussettes
c'est mes chaussettes
martin michaud c'est petit et ça n'a pas
marché donc là je suis toujours en
chaussette mouillée dans le son ya un
moment où dix mètres la daronne à l'abri
des doukkala maman vous êtes arrivé et
on est sûr de la mama très stylée pour
le courant pas du tout comme la mienne
quoi fins criminelles est sur les
épaules
en plus tu as dû mettre une veste un
parapluie aussi simple que ça attendez
j'ai pas fini
si en fait par action qu'est ce que ça a
duré deux minutes
on a des lacunes techniques quand il ya
trop de bonbons mais du gaffeur ici bas
d'écran du scotch quoi j'adore mes choux
ça tellement beau fait ce qu'on fait me
reconnais pas là-dedans et un coach
désapprouvé degré la simple shoot
[Musique]
là on arrive surtout dernier plan au nom
des autres a claqué mais tout le monde
est ultra des terres on est dans les
petites rues de lisbonne rien comme si
étroit pour faire les plans de faire un
coup devant et derrière donc au kendo
précédemment ce type de pc derrière tout
en faisant attention aux gens d'ailleurs
je suis bien beau placer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui